My left breast is literally rotting off my body. It is imploding, scabbing and oozing. It's about four fifths of the way gone. I asked
um
and he at my
an astrophactic practitioner or as is the nurse practitioner at the oncologist about it and she said that the sore
cancer
uh
will continue to
well that was extremely discouraging and upsetting but i don't accept that
it's going to keep on spreading a never stop if you have any suggestions as
as a topical to put on it or just leave it and let it take its course um well this comment
well by a doctor as well um that it's uh she said that the sore
the cancer will continue to spread and definitely is just absolutely foolishness that's not true
could it? yes um is it now? well that's the question just because it's destroyed
that it's destroyed the breast tissue the question really has it metastasized to
the chest wall is it metastasized to the lung is it metastasized to the lymph nodes
if the ends and to the ribs if the answer is no they don't think so
well then then what she said is just total nonsense if it is then it is metastasizing
as cancer dies and uh the tissue is going to be destroyed um so
it's um it uh so but to answer your question is there a topical or there topical things
yes there are topical things you could put on the cancer um it you know
and we discussed those with this person who asked this question a couple times um the you know
maybe to have a one-on-one would be the best thing to do because there's just so many different
topical things that you could put on a cancer when it's an open wound um and uh so that would
probably be the bit more appropriate than you do